hi will there be a chill Chums season
two well first of all I want to thank
Dave Grohl for being here
I get it all the time it is absolutely
amazing wow for a second I thought it is
so cool I know we have a cool podcast
but the fact that Dave Grohl would sit
in the back my friends look for me all
the time and they're like guys Dave
Grohl's here at the bar free drinks I'm
like I cannot cover this at all
you kind of sound like him too no and
you know what we've I've I've met him
many times uh and these the resemblance
is actually striking you could get away
with all kinds of stuff I was at a wine
tasting ones and the summer there was
like you know on the on the as a
sidekick I take photos or a bottle uh a
Bottle Rock and I'm his photographer I'm
like I met him before I'm like oh that's
sick like what's he like he's like he's
so nice but he's a little taller than
you and I'm like oh great fantastic yeah
yeah I um I just think if I were you I'd
be out signing checks in his name
renting limos and not paying for them I
got a free Denny's Grand Slam ones yeah
I'm running on that
I remembered once that years and years
ago there was someone who was pretending
to be me and driving around in a limo
and charging things
and I'm like of all the people you can
choose to pretend to be like who says
I'm Conan O'Brien apparently he didn't
even look that much like me but he was
riding around saying
oh Brian C put it on my account and I
don't know why that would work but
apparently it did you should all try it
um well sir who looks uh strikingly like
Dave Grohl I think even handsomer uh and
that's a compliment to you not to grow
tell me what uh what is your question
here yeah
yeah I couldn't listen to The Quest oh I
couldn't listen to the question because
I was saying it's Dave Grohl
what the is he doing here and so
the question just went out of my head oh
it was do is there plan for a new
chilchums there is yeah there's going to
be a chill Chums this summer it's in the
books as a matter of fact yeah it has
been the date has been set and we will
record a chill Chums and it's going to
be a fun one it's gonna be a really fun
time yeah um I have a question because
you've sir uh Mr scroll brought this up
which is will there be alcohol again
this time oh yeah I've already started
working up a cocktail oh cool because
the one last time was Lethal and Sona
very quickly was Blotto yeah yeah yeah
and this is true right my tolerance is
really low and I had one of it and I was
feeling no pain it was great I'm totally
down for another or we could take
Edibles no
well of course we'll have to check with
the sponsor oh okay right sorry that
sounds like no my AAA sponsor
that's the sponsor right now yeah
um yeah I know we're gonna do it that
was fun I remembered I was cautious I
sipped I sipped slowly because I'm a
broadcast professional oh we didn't sit
no we know we were chuggy you guys were
chugging and those were amazing drinks
you made thank you they were fantastic
yeah I gotta live up to it I I haven't
quite arrived there yet I don't know I'm
concocting I'm working on it get off my
back
like I'm threatened by any man that says
I'm concocting
get off my back
yeah well I'm always working on alcohol
oh okay very good yeah that's a good man
over there